los trabajadores de emergencia se
esfuerzan por apagar un incendio en este
vertedero que arde desde hace varios
días cubriendo gran parte de la zona con
una niebla tóxica el incendio fue
provocado por las semanas con
temperaturas récord en india y este es
sólo uno de los varios vertederos que se
han visto envueltos en llamas siendo los
residentes los más afectados a causa del
incendio en este vertedero nuestras
ventanas se han derretido y se sabe que
hay muchos contaminantes que entran en
las aulas donde los niños pueden estar
tranquilamente
en mi familia tienen problemas
respiratorios mis hijos tienen problemas
respiratorios mis suegros mi marido
tienen asma
de ver que barceló las temperaturas
abrasadoras que se espera aumenten aún
más este fin de semana no solo han
significado un peligro para la salud de
las personas sino también para las
cosechas en el país como segundo
productor mundial de trigo los países de
todo el mundo miran ahora a india para
tratar de compensar las carencias
causadas por la guerra en ucrania pero
el suministro parece incierto después de
que el calor dañará las cosechas en
marzo el mes más caliente desde que hay
registros
el mes de marzo es muy importante porque
es el momento en el que se produce el
llenado del grano este año hay varias
estimaciones que dicen que la caída
sería hasta de unas 10 millones de
toneladas menos por william a medida que
suben las temperaturas el alivio que
brinda el aire acondicionado tampoco
está garantizado porque el país se
enfrenta actualmente a su peor escasez
de electricidad en más de 6 años